it is time for this week's pet project
and amy lee joins us from nspca
and she brought along someone who needs
a safe and caring home
that is winter hey amy tell us the
winter is adorable tell us about winter
because she's so cute so she's my little
50 pound lap dog because she's
definitely making herself comfortable on
me uh winter is a such a beautiful
11 year old girl she's a healer pointer
mix is what we we have her listed as
that we believe she is
she's so sweet she's just the perfect
temperament
um we're just looking for the perfect
home for her she just needs a caring
home because she does have some skin
allergies so she does take some daily
medication for that
um but i think with dedication i mean
that's really all she asks for she asks
for a loving home she needs just to be
cared for with her medication
um and she's on a fish-based diet for
her allergies
but i mean this girl is super active for
an 11 year old girl i mean you wouldn't
know that she's
super spunky she loves to go and walk
she loves to play i mean
how can you not fall in love with his
face i mean she's gorgeous oh she is
adorable and i can kind of see the
healer mix
in in her face and in her mask how is
she with other dogs
she's she is sweet she did come to the
shelter with another dog but she
um with proper introduction so we always
preface that you know you don't just
throw
uh two strange dogs in a room together
and expect them to get along right away
you know we will give you our adoption
counselors will walk you through
proper introductions with a current dog
if you do have one at home
um otherwise she could be fine just on
her own um but you know she she really
just
needs a great loving family and she's
gonna just blend in perfectly
she is adorable and now energy levels
she's a good walker
is she a good napper she's pretty much
the good
everything she's great just great
everything great energy she's so gentle
and
super affectionate i mean she'd be great
on walks she'd be great watching netflix
with you and you can binge watch
whatever
with her on the couch she's great i mean
she's just a sweet wonderful dog
we will we will find her home because
she she's a cutie she's 50 pounds of
pure love
thank you so much amy we appreciate it
and if you're interested in adopting a
pet go to nevadaspca.org or call them
at 702-873-7722
rocky over to you